cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
we've got this report maybe we have to
get into this this is this is big well
this is big Tim because we're talking
about world war three Yahoo news the new
voice of Ukraine is the publication
they're rebroadcasting U.S to hold
closed-door meeting over whether
billionaire is conducting own foreign
policy question mark is Elon Musk a
traitor now think about what's
insinuated in that headline so Elon Musk
isn't allowed to have a dissenting
opinion
Elon Musk isn't allowed to have his own
policy with his own company's property
yeah like he is the owner of SpaceX he
owns all those what color is your house
painted uh my house yeah uh it's wood
well that's illegal you no crap but wait
wait no you have to have a blue house
now you traitor this this is just like
Iron Man 2. remember in the beginning
when Tony Stark is at the Congressional
hearing and they're like we want the
Iron Man weapon turned over to the
government and he's like you can't have
it
yeah I didn't I didn't make that
connection right another aspect to this
too which is they're laying the
groundwork to go after him on the Logan
act right that he is a private citizen
carrying out American foreign policy in
an unauthorized way that's what they
tried to do to General Flynn right it's
all bogus again but it sounds also
Senator Elizabeth Warren today or
yesterday came forward and demanded that
the Pentagon uh conduct their own
investigation into Elon they're going to
try to nationalize Starling I mean
they're going after they're going after
Tesla they're going after him in every
possible way and it Harkens back to
Senator Chuck Schumer talking about
Trump saying well if you go after the
Deep State they have six ways to Sunday
to come out after you again well Elon
now who's you know certainly an elite
richest man in the world they're
targeting him so which what they're
doing is and it's the same thing with
you Owen as it is with Elon and the j6
defendants these are all messaging
events they're messaging events it's
don't even think about it don't even
think about standing up for the Bill of
Rights Free Speech uh Second Amendment
don't even think about standing up for
your country or we will destroy you
yeah it doesn't matter if you're the
richest man in the world or you're Owen
or you or me musk needs to make sure
that he has a a a one-button kill switch
that just gets all of the satellites to
fall out of orbit should they try to
nationalize and just burn up in in on
reentry
take the uh the option away from them
but they they I really do think they're
going to try and
try to nationalize SpaceX they're going
to say that his ability to access the
internet and and put the internet in
places that they don't want it and his
ability to put significant uh sizable
Rockets into space and stuff they're
going to say that that's National
Security and they're going to try now
and and let's also think about what this
is going to do to Elon musk's political
beliefs and actions I mean I can't it's
only to make it more like on our side
that's what I'm saying I can't believe
that he's going to sit here and say oh
the Biden Administration is right I
should have let them use my technology
to kill Russians to start Newton they're
radicalizing Elon Musk to be a
deplorable absolutely and he's like hey
I just want to be a normal dude and have
common sense but that's the thing ever
like Mo your average person generally if
they don't get fed the news from CNN
then and or at least kind of if they're
not very interested in the news or
whatever and they are told the topics
that you you hear people talking about
stuff they tend to come down on what you
would consider a normal person's
perspective not a a democrat's
perspective because
ever since and I I'm not going to get
too deep into this but ever since
2012 uh the ndaa when they they uh did
these the Smith munt modernization Act
which made it legal for the federal
government to propagandize the American
people that was Obama that was Obama it
was 2012 they signed it I think or maybe
it was 2011 they signed and there's the
2013 but either way
um that's when it happened and after
that everybody that I talked to you talk
to people all the time they say oh you
know in like 2013 two or so things
started getting crazy they blame it on
the uh the my end of the Mayan calendar
and there's all these things but what
happened was it became legal for the
government to propagandize the American
people at the same time there was Market
saturation of your cell phones
smartphones so everyone had social media
directly in there in their pocket and it
was constantly feeding them a drip of
likes which is literally the most
powerful mind control thing ever created
so the federal government got the access
to it and they knew that it was coming
because they they saw social media when
it first started in 2004 whenever
Friendster or whatever
um but they saw it and there are smart
people that said that's going to be a
big deal the like button is going to be
a big deal and as soon as it was in your
pocket and the government had their
fingers in producing propaganda all of
the social media companies came running
because the government prints the money
because that it's all access so all the
regular media they want to be buddies
with Obama and be buddies with people in
power so they go ahead and they
capitulate and they come running it's
not that there's an adversarial or there
has been an adversarial uh relationship
between the federal government and and
the media they've been one in the same
and then you start and then you throw in
the fact that there's an entire uh
security apparatus that was built up
after after 2001 and you put those three
things together the American people have
no chance well they have no chance it's
just like when the government was
testing the flicker rates of the TV to
make it as addictive as possible before
they released it but you know I I
had an amazing connection listening to
you say that and and Tim this is going
to take a trip down memory lane because
what happened in 2013 it was the Mike
Brown riots and and you remember that
was when 14 that was 14. that was when
live streaming really kind of first took
off and really that was a big movement
on Twitter and what was it it was it was
hands up don't shoot well if you ask if
you were to ask me uh the Arab Spring
was the first time we started seeing the
emergence of independent live streaming
I think the guy's name was uh was it
Muhammad nabous I believe was the guy in
in Libya and it was fairly rudimentary
and then with Occupy Wall Street we saw
people with webcams on their laptops and
then the Ustream app came out I don't
know of anyone else before me that
started using it but I started using the
Ustream app to live broadcast from my
phone on the ground with a Mobile
Battery yeah that occupied all right
2011. and then and then you were doing
the same thing at the Mike Brown riots
and and because I was there doing the
same thing too but the reason I'm making
this connection is because hands up
don't shoot might have been the first
institutionalization of that act hands
up don't shoot never happened it was the
number one trend on Twitter and other
social media marketplaces for months it
never happened it caused riots they
still chant hands up don't ship to this
day even though the Obama doj admitted
it never happened could that have been
the first test case of the smithmont ACT
I mean I don't know I I don't know for
sure but the the the fact that you had
people on CNN you know repeating the
narrative it definitely uh it may be
when NBC News was taken over by the
intelligence agencies I think if if
there was going to be any news outlet
that I thought was under the under the
boot you know people make fun of CNN and
I'm like CNN's just garbage NBC News is
like
the evil just you know the and I'm
talking about their their digital uh
Team they've got a team of writers who I
won't say their names because they don't
want to give them the attention but
they're they're abject evil yep they
there there's no the things they've
published are such obvious Fabrications
that I don't see a reality in which
they're unaware that they're lying
cheating and stealing for political
power and so a lot of people speculate
that they're probably
you know uh what happens is
someone from an intelligence agency will
come to them and say we need this story
to run for this purpose and they'll go
you got a boss thanks for the scoop
and then they just they run with the
machine wants them to run and they get
their paycheck oh yeah and they have no
problem with it none oh no they're
willing participants there's so many
reporters that are you know active
willing organs for the security State
and just propagandize the American
people this gets back to where we were
at earlier and again it's such a
mind-boggling thing like really Obama is
a scandal-free president like you don't
you don't actually believe that the free
president that shot missiles at American
citizens without due process I mean free
fast and furious but it's like it's the
same thing it's like oh Biden he's so
fit look he's more fit than Trump he's
totally and it's just like you don't
actually believe that Joe Biden fell up
the stairs
yeah fell off why do you guys think he
ran out of that metal ceremony I think
he crapped his pants yeah that's like
yeah oh yes right and and the media came
out and said it's
it wasn't that big deal that he left the
way he did and it's like it it was kind
of abrupt I mean call whatever you want
you could argue it wasn't informal but
it's it's abrupt for him not to hang out
and shake hands and and smile and meet
people afterwards yeah he he probably
had a a bowel movement and I think the
fair and I think the fair way to analyze
this and it's not about obsessing over
what aboutism I think what about ism is
fair it shows you whether you have
Justice it shows you whether you have
fairness let's just let's just ask the
question if Donald Trump walked out of a
medal of honor ceremony can you imagine
the headlines they'd accuse him of
everything it's not it's it's not
hypocrisy it's it's uh By Design
hierarchy yeah yeah that's right thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time